let's go next to
where do we want to go there's so many
people who want to be on let's go to
saigon mike saigon mike you're next
saigon mike
you're unmuted but i'm wondering if you
have the wrong audio device selected
and last chance for saigon mike to fix
your audio
all right that's too bad saigon mike is
gone let's go next to steve from chicago
steve welcome
hey david can you hear me yes i can
um yes so i was wondering i know we've
been kind of talking about uh you
brought joe rogan a little bit ago and
he said when he brought up um
his liking for desantis and you kind of
brought up he maybe doesn't really know
what he's talking about but do you think
the possibility maybe
that he sees more in line even though he
is a progressive
he sees more in line with some of the
stuff that um
desantis is doing and isn't really happy
with uh some stuff that like uh denver
kind of presents we doing like with
biden
uh no that sounds weird to me i mean if
if rogan
is more progressive
he couldn't possibly like what desantis
is doing if he knows what desantis is
doing
but i i uh but i'm saying is that
the way that the
he he can still be progressive but not
like the that things that the democratic
party is going too far and that the
santas would be that the zanthus and
people like the scientists might isn't
as far right as they're actually saying
or as extreme well i mean you're saying
is it possible that something rogan
hasn't said is what's in his head and
it's like i guess so but we have no
reason to think that that's what rogan
thinks it's sort of like mind reading
you know
no no like i guess an
example
for me is that the whole the way that
the progressive movement has been going
with uh trying to
push like uh puberty blockers on
children and the trans athletes which is
like i know a subject that
uh joe rogan opposes what the way that's
going and that someone may be on the
right
that it would be more open to his view
of like how the that that should be uh
played
i'm not aware of
the movement among progressives to push
puberty blockers on kids can you tell me
more about that
uh
wasn't the
health secretary literally out there
saying that
the kids should be able to transition
and use puberty blockers
if they feel like they're in the wrong
body
oh uh okay because first you said that
there were there was a movement pushing
puberty blockers on kids it sounds like
what you're saying is
one biden administration official said
that for the tiny percentage of people
in that situation and the subsection
within that that wants to pursue such
drugs that it should be possible is that
what you're what you actually meant
um i
mean the first thing you said was that
progressives are pushing puberty
blockers on kids but then your example
wasn't that was it
i mean
okay pushing the idea of using
puberty blockers on kids if you want to
be more
straightforward about it well when you
say that it sounds like you're saying
that there's a movement to just convince
children to take puberty blockers but
there isn't any movement like that is
there
um
it seems there's a movement
i would say so okay so who is going
around saying hey what we want is we
want more kids to take puberty blockers
who's saying that
uh
the fighting administration for kids who
want to take puberty blockers
oh but so what you're saying is the
biden administration
has a position that
in certain situations for the tiny
percentage of kids who identify as being
in the wrong body for lack of a better
term
and for whom
medical professionals believe it would
be appropriate to make that decision
it should be a decision they are allowed
to make right because that's very
different than they are pushing puberty
blockers on kids
uh i would say
anyone like i guess the well let me give
you an example to make it really clear
oh what i guess let me let me let me let
me clarify i guess from our my spot
before you give your example sorry i'm
going to interrupt you just so you can
do your comeback um so i guess from joe
rogan's perspective is that the kid like
a kid that age let's just say
five six younger than that
like we they can't they can't enter into
contracts they can't do other stuff
because they don't have the mental
capacity to actually understand yep if
they're it maybe would be in the wrong
body or not in the wrong body or
anything like that and i'm not talking
about adults or anything i'm talking
about kids got it that it would be it
and the harmful effects they could have
on tv boxers with them and their mind
not being able to fully understand
what's going on would you apply that
same logic to children getting vaccines
where the kids can't actually consent
themselves the parents are doing it for
them and they don't understand the full
impact of those and once you do it you
can't undo the fact that you've gotten a
vaccine would you apply the same
standard to the vaccines i'm curious
uh
vaccines um
it's very
interesting um
no i guess i
i wouldn't but i guess i would i guess
i said i guess i'm going back to like do
kids actually understand i think i can
understand more of a vaccine if they're
if the parent talks about them
talks about it to them so it sounds like
you're saying it's actually not about
whether the kids can or can't sign
contracts or are of legal age it's
whether they can understand a concept
based on what their parents tell them
that's the standard you're now laying
out
no i'm not i'm not saying there's a
standard saying that well i'm asking
forcing
oh my standard is right i i don't think
i i i i don't think kids
understand exactly what they're doing
with the the puberty blockers and more
of the long-term effects that could have
on them
versus like a vaccine i guess which is
which is different i mean look i'm sure
but like
in a few in a few weeks my daughter will
be due for vaccines she can't understand
them and no matter how i explain it to
her she's not gonna understand them by
your standard about understanding i
shouldn't be allowed to get her
vaccinated right
uh i'm not saying i'm not saying i don't
think she'd be allowed to uh get her
vaccinated i'm not right what i'm asking
you is you said the standard that makes
vaccines different than puberty blockers
is
the kids better understand vaccines
rather than their understanding of
puberty blockers i just explained my
daughter doesn't understand vaccines at
all should by your standard
she should not i should not be able to
get her vaccinated in a couple weeks
based on your standard
i i didn't say that was a standard of
mine i was saying no i literally asked
you what's your standard and you said
that's your standard my standard is they
can't understand it
not on vaccines i guess i say i was
saying my understanding would be
able to explain vaccines versus puberty
blockers and the whole and all the side
effects moving forward
transitioning and everything like that i
mean okay i
i'm but again i'm basically i'm what was
my basic question is
my base my basic going back to the joe
rogan part was yeah more under uh and i
i guess i don't know why i guess my
pushing
is uh i'm not saying they're just like
going up and giving up kids puberty
blockers but more of the emphasis on
transitioning
younger kids when it when the long-term
effects
they probably won't be able to
understand what's actually going on with
their body got it so let's so let's say
let's now drill down to what we are
talking about so
you're not saying that they are let's go
just follow me step by step you're not
saying anyone is forcing puberty
blockers physically into children right
you're not making the claim anybody's
doing that no if that came across that
way that's not true no no i'm not saying
it i'm just i'm let me clear up so
you're not saying anyone is forcibly
being given puberty blockers good second
is there any campaign to go out and say
hey kids
consider puberty blockers it's cool like
is there a pr campaign or you're saying
there isn't that either
um i wouldn't say there's a pr campaign
to like say it's cool but i think
there's a
campaign
strategy of movement of like putting
more of a
uh
spotlight on them
for younger for younger kids basically
in
uh
with
doctors schools that within the
administration everything so you're
saying that there are schools where they
do presentations and then go hey kids if
you're not feeling good about your body
how about puberty blockers that's
happening somewhere
i wouldn't say that they would say pure
blockers in there but say within schools
they're trying they're
more or less i guess going into like uh
gender identity
and everything in every sexuality and
everything like that which would would
bring the conversation moving towards
that do you have any evidence that in
schools where they talk about the fact
that trans people exist they're pushing
puberty blockers is there a single
example of such a school
um i mean wait do like the example where
they're mentioning puberty blockers in
like the like the teachers said the word
puberty blockers yeah where they're
saying not when when issues of gender
are taught in schools
where puberty blockers are being talked
about by teachers and presented as
something to pursue or something you
said remember at the beginning of the
call you said pushing the word was
pushing i'm looking for someone so
i'm not saying again i like i said i
don't think that they're like the
teachers themselves are saying
uh are pushing
puberty blocker like they're going in
the same puberty blockers i'm saying
that the com like the thought process
and the the transition to the end result
with transitioning if you rebrockers is
in like um
you may not like pushing the whole idea
again i'm not i if adult wants to make a
decision i'm not against anything at all
i'm saying kids definitely pushing ideas
no steve i got that but you you started
the call by saying that something is
being pushed and we've gone piece by
piece and you're acknowledging you can't
actually identify anyone pushing it
i mean everyone i ask you is this person
pushing it is that person pushing it you
go well no so now you're saying i'm not
even
yeah i mean the bible administration is
encouraging kids
okay no but no steve now we're back to
the beginning that was your first claim
which already fell apart all right steve
thank you for the call i'm gonna let you
go by the way i'm not even taking a
position
for or against puberty blockers for kids
like i don't know enough about it to say
maybe it's not a good idea maybe i'm not
taking a position
that caller had no idea what he was
talking about okay